je suis à liez evren président de la
fédération les républicains de paris et
vice président de la région ile de
france en charge de la culture et du
patrimoine la culture est un puissant
moteur de cohésion sociale tout
particulièrement dans une société
fracturée comme la nôtre et nous devons
et c'est un défi pour nous nous adresser
à tout le monde alors je ferai campagne
avec ma sensibilité avec mon parcours
avec mes convictions et fidèle à notre
famille politique
l'enjeu est crucial avec une poussée
très forte des populismes européen notre
famille politique doit aujourd'hui
relever deux défis ou 2 impasse la
première impasse c'est l'europe proposé
par emmanuel macron une robe sans limite
une europe sans frontières une europe
fédéraliste qui dû lire l union
européenne dans la mondialisation
la deuxième un pass c'est l'europe
proposé par marine le pen
une europe avec un freak site qui serait
un véritable désastre pour la france un
désastre pour l'europe et un saut dans
l'inconnu
nous voulons une europe qui protège
davantage ses frontières une europe qui
protège également ses frontières
extérieures
comptez sur nous pour faire une campagne
soudée et efficace dans l'intérêt de la
france et dans l'intérêt des français